let's talk about the
becoming exclusive too fast because this
is uh something a lot of guys
um contend with very badly in fact
the where do we stand talk okay
and i had a hilarious conversation with
a
roommate of mine back in my 20s i
remember he was dating this
uh this girl and
uh he said to me
well he was my roommate so he's at the
front door and he comes by afterwards
to where i'm at because i'm hanging out
in the back of the house and he goes ah
you know i just had to talk with her at
the front door i'm like what's that
because you know she's asking where i
stood
and from the outside it's easy to be
alpha right so i said to my go
what did you tell her that the way i see
it we're standing at the front door and
i'm seeing you off sort of thing
it's incredibly important that you as a
guy don't bring up the
where do we stand talk okay the word
that we stand talk has to come from her
you're you're in charge you are the
gatekeeper to relationships as a man
if you're going to invite a woman into
your life and you want to get into an
ltr with her or marriage you know
again guys i'm vehemently opposed to
marriage i've talked about it a hundred
thousand times but many of you are not
going to listen to me so i'm just
broadly speaking about this
you do what you want with your life but
if you're going to get
involved with a woman on a longer term
basis and she's looking for
more security more closeness and
invitation into your inner life you know
we often draw
a perimeter and you know we have we have
women
on the inside of the perimeter and on
the outside of the perimeter most of you
guys should be keeping women on the
outside of the perimeter there's only a
very
a small handful of women that should
ever be allowed on the inner perimeter
and they should only be allowed there
after you spend plates and they get
promoted to basically
the best after all the crap falls off
sort of thing and even then they aren't
perfect trust me
so when you get exclusive too fast and
you have the where do we stand talk and
you bring it up as a guy
which is what most guys do whenever i
have these consults with them and
they're telling me the story about how
it all happened and how it all unfolded
it's them that brought up the where do
we stand talk again
you're starting from a very bad position
you're starting from a position of
neediness
you're starting from a position where
you're basically stepping on her toes
she's the one that's looking for
security from you
okay she's the one that if she sees you
as a high enough value guy
should be coming up to you and being
like hey rich take your vibe
have a lot of fun with you let's you
know where do we stand sort of thing
and even then if it's too early on the
way you should be seeing it is
i'm seeing at the front door and i'm
standing here seeing you off for the
evening can't wait to see you next
whatever right you have to be you have
to protect
that inner perimeter okay so
make sure that you're clear on who
you're going to let on the inside of
that
and give it time if you're going to let
somebody in on the inner perimeter
it should be again because you're
spinning plates so
the next point that i should make here
that i have in my notes
is one of the big mistakes that guys
make that jeopardizes
them on a long-term basis or you know
gets them in a position where they get
dumped by a check that they're pining
for
is they don't spin plates they they date
they get kind of mediocre results or not
the greatest
and there's maybe one girl that gives
them enough attention
that they then like double down and just
like laser focus on and they throw
everything at her
they throw everything the kitchen sink
the flowers
the booking on the long weekend away to
wherever
you know the lake house niagara falls
whatever is it you're trying to do to
impress her
and then you just get right into the
where do we stand right away within
a month or two okay i've done it i've
done it in the past trust me i know
how stupid it is today but what you need
to do is stretch out that timeline quite
a bit
what you need to do guys is
date in a non-monogamous fashion with a
bunch of women simultaneously
and see where the best ones are because
if that's what your goal is if you're
looking for an ltr you're looking for
something
you know beyond that your goal should be
have some experiences
okay get out there experience female
nature
because the only way that you're going
to discern the better ones from the
worst ones
is by spinning plates you need contrast
you can't
you can't appreciate daylight and a hot
noon sun
if you haven't experienced the cold
darkness of 4am
right you need contrast in your life as
guys
to get your head around this to get some
clarity
you